in 1947 the first h m store opened in
Sweden and by 2019 there were over 5 000
H M's around the world about 3 000 more
than its competitor Zara how long have
you waiting this morning in the queue
it collaborated with fashion giants like
Versace Belmont and Carl Lagerfeld
the world has changed what we do today
will Define our tomorrow but recently h
m has struggled the company's net income
dropped during the pandemic and 2022 was
one of the store's least profitable
years in over two decades that same year
h m laid off 1500 employees
so what went wrong
this morning major American companies
pulling business out of Russia Disney
Warner Brothers Exxon Mobil Ford Russia
was H M's sixth largest market but after
Russia invaded Ukraine h m decided to
close all of its stores in Russia and
stop online sales to the country the
company cited operational challenges and
an unpredictable future they of course
faced this unprecedented situation like
a lot of Brands last year with Russia's
invasion of Ukraine that forced them to
close a lot of stores in what was one of
their bigger markets about five percent
of their Global sales so h m would argue
that without that hit they would have
had a fairly decent last year our
decision to wind down the business there
has had a significant significant
negative impact on our results the war
also helped fuel inflation increasing
raw material and logistical costs
besides pulling out of Russia h m has
had long-standing problems in China
another important
markets
consumers in China boycotted the company
in 2021 after h m raised concerns about
alleged forced labor and discrimination
against ethnic minorities in China's
cotton production Chinese consumers and
online retail apps like tmall pinduodor
and JD boycotted h m map apps like Baidu
also removed h m from their platforms
they've never really recovered from that
issue they're still trying to find a way
back into the China Market h m also
faced a setback when coveted lockdowns
in China led to store closures in the
country
[Music]
first I Got This Hood
This Hood actually
one big one big factor they face is is
their brand position they're a fast
fashion brand so all about being
relatively cheap
but in recent years they've faced this
new competition from online fast fashion
players like xiin who are even cheaper
even quicker to to get new designs onto
the market Sheen has come onto the
market as one of H M's fast fashion
competitors and unlike h m Sheehan is an
online only retailer they don't have
physical stores that's their model on
the other hand h m relies heavily on
in-store sales only about 30 percent of
its sales come from online so h m faces
this this predicament that on the on the
low side there being out flanked by
Xi'an and online players but do you try
and trade up because if you do then
you're coming into direct competition
with a brand like Zara which in the mind
of a lot of consumers is a slightly
higher end brand they've already closed
something like 12 of their Global stores
and analysts generally think that's the
right way to go that you close the
underperforming stores invest in the
best stores because most consumers still
like to shop in physical stores but then
also try and build up the digital side
as well but can h m get customers
excited about the brand again fashion is
a tricky business of course because it
relies a lot on this sort of intangible
idea of brand heat and whether your
brand resonates with consumers and H M
seems to have lost a little bit of that
resonance with a lot of consumers can
they
get consumers excited again about about
h m close at the price point they're at
and at the moment they maybe they're
having some success but I think they'd
like to see a lot more to really get
young consumers especially back on board